hi I'm Eric Voss and we got a new
trailer for Marvel's ant-man and the
wasp coming July 6 giving us new books
at Scott Lang and hope Van Dyne as the
wasp showing us her very literal
interpretation of Blade Runner this
trailer is so fun but really let's be
honest it's only the second best and man
trailer now let's throw a pins particle
disc on this trailer blow it up to
scrutinize it frame by frame that's a
little force but you go in I mean we're
gonna talk about all this new tech the
villain the stuff you might have missed
in yeah if any of my general predictions
and Athene right possible spoilers ahead
let's get started I just have one
question
when cap needed help if I'd asked you
would you have come I guess we'll never
know but if you had you'd have never
been caught okay after this opening shot
of Oakland Bay Bridge overlooking
downtown San Francisco we get some
reminders of where we last saw ant-man
fighting alongside team cap at the
Leipzig Airport in Captain America Civil
War so for any of you with questions
about the timeline this is all taking
place after Civil War actually the
Avengers infinity war prelude comic that
just came out established that after cap
broke his buddies out of the raft prison
at the Indus civilization a bit but the
fact that they're referencing civil wars
suggests that this story will be set
before infinity war even though this
movie's gonna come out two months after
that movie does yeah it's a little
confusing like if they're chat here came
after infinity war you'd think Scott
would reference the more recent and more
apocalyptic team-up event as opposed to
that relatively smaller stakes boy fight
over what was it super heroes having or
nametags anyway a man in the mosque is
looking like a fun side adventure
focusing on the relationship between
these two heroes separate from the
bigger world changing MCU events hopes
line here might be an inside joke to the
fact that her character was originally
planned to appear in Captain America
Civil War according to the screenwriter
Stephen McFeely she was cut because they
didn't really have time to establish the
wasps origin as her own character oh
wait there's more trailer here let's
move on to the next section
[Music]
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run so this is cool
Marvel Studios logo pops into frame like
it's using Pym particles but also listen
closely the music here this guitar riff
is the song ants invasion by the band
atom in the ants get it cuz ants we also
see how Scott Lang is now under house
arrest strapped with an ankle bracelet
now if I had to guess that bracelet
could be specifically modified by the
feds to prevent Scott from shrinking
down out of it or maybe it's just too
snug to fit a suit underneath it perhaps
after escaping the raft Scott was able
to arrange a special deal with the
government to let him stand her house
arrest instead of you know throwing him
back in there like maybe he has an
arrangement where he's doing these
contract missions for them now to stay
out of that prison regardless it looks
like the beginning of this movie will
deal with the consequences of Scott's
decision to participate in those broader
superhero conflicts just to find why
ant-man stories are set in a smaller
more grounded world his characters of
reason want to stay out of that stuff
and those consequences include throwing
that exposure on Hank and hope as well
with the government probably wanting to
know the source of that Pym technology
that is now going viral online thanks to
Peter Parker's youtube uploads let's
move on we're still running let's go
ah so this section has my favorite part
of this trailer hank pym shrinking down
a building into luggage and yeah this is
pretty nuts hank tipping it like that as
he rolls it away probably would cause
all the furniture inside to slide around
except if you think about it Hank
probably designed this building as a
smaller model and constructed it on a
small scale where the interiors could be
designed like a doll house with
everything glued down or like magnetized
in place I mean seriously what
contractor is gonna build a massive
sliding handle on the roof of a building
this guy what's a handle on top and big
wheels on a bomb yeah no builder I guess
also if you look closely you'll notice
God is wearing a bathrobe here and he
doesn't have his FBI ankle bracelet
anymore so this could be part of a scene
where Hank and Hope drag him out of bed
and help him slip the feds that could be
why we saw the feds surrounding them at
gunpoint early in the trailer next
there's a shot of this vessel warming up
now we see this thing later shrunken
down it's one of the many vehicles Pym
has equipped with sighs manipulating
technology in the movie there's also
this shot of Hope looking very concerned
but she's standing in front of this
purple car with sick flame design on the
hood now this shows up late in the
trailer and I'm thinking that like the
rollaway building this could be a toy
car that's been blown up to huge size to
me that design definitely looks a lot
like a Hot Wheels in general I'm just
very pumped to see how fun this sequel
seems to be having with size
manipulation gags I really don't think
we can get enough that next there's this
shot in a lab with some strange ripple
effects going on inside a chamber now
have some thoughts on this in a second
but first we got our first look at
Laurence Fishburne's character he's
playing Bill Foster who in the comics is
also the superhero Goliath now it's not
certain if we'll see him use those
powers in this movie it sounds like
he'll just be a biochemist and former
collaborator of Hank Pym and so it
sounded like Foster might be from that
older generation of heroes when Hank and
his wife Janet carried the ant-man and
wasp titles actually while we're on that
subject this trailer didn't give us
really any details about michelle
pfeiffer as janet but she will be in
this movie
maybe Foster's role actually in the
story is to help rescue Janet from the
quantum realm where she disappeared into
and although I would say this trailer is
heavier on the cool action shots of the
wasp we do
one great shot of ant-man shrinking down
to straddle what looks like a flying ant
yes this shot is very cool and I have a
fun fact about this real quick thanks to
our sponsors Skillshare for helping us
make this video Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes on pretty much everything it's
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and do
the work you love for me I'm a writer
and host trying to learn how to edit
these kind of videos too so that's so
much out of Jordi van der foots learned
video editing on Premiere Pro CC I also
want to learn animation with After
Effects and Filip inners dive into After
Effects flat animation build up was
great for that skill share is way more
affordable than most learning platforms
out there an annual subscription is less
than $10 a month but we're even gonna do
a special offer just for you guys sign
up right now and get the first three
months of skill share for just 99 cents
this is only supposed to be available in
January but Skillshare extended it just
for you guys to February 15th just sign
up at sk l dot sh / new rockstars 99 or
click on the link at the top of the
description below
seriously this really officer channel so
for every sign up i will undo one bit
okay fine for every sign of all button
up another button guys only have so many
buttons ok back to this shot with scott
writing the flying in well ants can run
upwards of 30 miles per hour their
airspeed is a lot slower probably closer
to that of a housefly which is only
about 4 and a half miles per hour so in
other words if ant-man is jumping on
this to speed ahead and catch up to a
car or escape another car he'd probably
just be better up running again maybe he
was just tired he wasn't in a rush you
know this is probably why people say
nerds are ruining movies
[Music]
all right in this section we see some
shots of a street chase sequence with
Scott and hope escape being a gang of
bikers in this pimped out SUV now the
close up of these gray gloves on the
bike belonged to this character
this is ghost the villain of this movie
in the comics ghost is a villain who
butted heads with Iron Man Stark
Industries he has the power to become
invisible or intangible allowing him to
pass through surfaces kind of like Kitty
Pryde from the x-men but he also has the
power to take over electronic devices in
this movie they change ghosts genders
she's being played by Hannah John Kaman
and I'm pretty sure that that was ghosts
arms and hands that we were seeing
earlier this might be what it looks like
when her body materializes in this shot
check out those red eye pieces those
could be the infrared sensors that Ghost
uses to see through surfaces before she
passes through them I also just love
this whole hood design it gives ghosts a
truly spectral appearance now another
villain appears in this section if
you're looking closely in the front seat
of this SUV is Walton Goggins character
Sonny birch now the comics birch is a
corporate baddie who works as a weapons
contractor for cross industries and he's
buddies with Obadiah Stane my guess is
he's chasing down Scott in hope trying
to get his hands on some of that pin
technology actually later in this
section you can see birch again
clutching a briefcase on the ferry as
ant-man turns into a giant man and Rises
out of the water so piecing this all
together with a few other shots we've
seen Sonny Burton ghosts are chasing
Scott and hope in their PIM Mystery
Machine and then they pull this cool
move of shrinky down and resizing to
flip over one of their pursuers and I
thought how there's a turn of events
where birch gets what he's seeking and
tries to escape on a ferry which
actually few remember we saw in the
opening shots of the trailer and then
giant Scott rises out of the water
ursula styled a snatch it back also it
looks like Michael Pena as Lewis will be
involved in this car chase I think he
might be the one driving that hopefully
Hot Wheels car really I would just love
an ant-man and the wasp is just one
extended chase heist with a tech
football being swapped back and forth
kind of the way a baby driver was
actually wouldn't be cool for baby
drivers director Edgar Wright to direct
an ant-man movie oh wait
and before we move on there's a very
interesting shot of that vessel I
pointed out before shrunken way down to
near microscopic levels now these tiny
creatures look a lot like tardigrades
eight-legged segmented micro animals
nicknamed water bears that kind of look
like chubby gummi bears and not to geek
out over bugs again but they are awesome
and shouldn't breed more
about them there were also some rumors
that ant-man in the wasp would feature
giant insects attacking downtown San
Francisco so I'm wondering that these
guys are the ones that will appear in
some macro form just you know imagine
how gross and awesome that would be as
we watch this next section you just need
someone watching your back like a
partner
okay after a moment between Scott and
his daughter Cassie there are these
amazing shots of the wasp in action
taking down a few grunts in a fancy
restaurant kitchen really all we want to
point out here is the gymnast level
precision the wasp shows as she dodges
these Knights she tucks her body into a
thin line even folding in her wings and
then after dodging the first one she
fans out those wings and uses them to
level herself and propel herself forward
also how many large cutting knives this
is dude have this rate he would have had
like pan out just three ready to go
chucking them super fast with an amazing
name who is its bull's eye
moving on you gave her wings and
blasters so I take it you didn't have
that tech available for me no I did
just a fun bit of dialogue here between
Scott and Hank with Hank implying that
trusting an ex-con with a shrinking suit
that also has wings and blasters what a
bid probably a step too far then we
close out on a shot of Scott riding
behind wasps but then we smash cut to
this amazing title card with each letter
blowing up in size synchronized to the
notes of Adam and the ants guitar riff I
just love how vibrant and comic-book E
this title is very fun and kitschy
the diagonal design reminds me a lot of
that back to the future title card it
just looks like this whole movie will
embrace this fun irony which I'm very
excited about oh right and one last
little bit of this trailer that's so
great one one I've never imagined a
Hello Kitty PEZ dispenser would be so
dangerous but here we are to me this
seems like a heightened gag building on
the way they use Thomas the Tank Engine
in the first movie and that fuel truck
ant-man through at war machine and Civil
War a question for you guys do you think
ant-man and the wasps powers could at
all be useful against Thanos I don't
really remember seeing ant-man in the
infinity war trailer maybe he's there on
some microscopic level and part of me
thinks it could only be truly useful in
some kind of side mission that
contributes to the overall fight back
against Thanos but I don't know watching
this trailer could be interesting to see
these two use something like the quantum
realm to destabilize Thanos from the
inside out the way a man was able to
screw up Tony Stark's Iron Man armor and
Civil War comment with your thoughts
down below or tweet me directly at ei
vas and follow new rockstars on Twitter
at new rockstars for updates under
videos like and share this video and
subscribe didn't rock stars for
breakdowns of all the Marvel stuff you
love Avengers infinity war black panther
thor ragnarok guys we got it all same
match was even going back to watch all
the other MCU movies that we get to
infinity war and if you really want to
help this channel you can contribute to
us on patreon big thanks to all our
generous especially Pony Stark thanks
for watching bye